YouTube this is a barista speaking from
the religious faith community and the
WEF a few questions that have been put
forward to us one of them is concerning
the global crisis on the economy
well the question always seems to be
when and how can we recover there's a
problem with that from my points of view
should we be looking for recovery to go
back to where we've been to just really
repeat the mistakes that we've already
found out now or should we be learning
from the crisis that's I suppose the
real debate that's that we need to be
addressing clearly the principles
understand is that were in place the
regulations they felt alongside degreed
of the people that's why were involved
in this you will probably have heard
from cash Bob the idea of a Hippocratic
oath for business some kind of rules of
ethics I think also that is a bit sir
well self-contradicting in some cases
yes there's a good intention did the key
question on all the reporters lifts the
one I've been asked maybe about six
times by different media people is is
there any redemption for the bank as
well incentive from this nine points of
view as you can see on the center stands
as an imam redemption is an important
and valid tool for all humans to utilize
but one of the conditions of that is
sincerity and have we seen any sincerity
on behalf of those people who have
committed these crimes and they are
crimes much as fraud and corruption and
greed but clearly the a trying to get
away with whatever they can get away
with I think having seen the person who
is trying to get back to an original
state of level of profits and level of
business I think they need to ask the
question are they really wanted to run
down the difference between how we
approach the economy and how someone
else such as a current comes to the
system that's his base upon usury the
excessive leverage of interest and
profit based upon the power of money
itself no we say that venture capitalism
is a is probably the closest way to
explain how an equity great system would
never have allowed this to occur so
that's me that's our take has the
religious community on the issue of the
economy there's too many people
wanting to borrow money that's not there
for things that they don't need we need
to take account of ourselves we need to
start to reflect upon our actions and I
think that's it I've chosen the boring
topic because the religion one implicit
Swan River but if the bar on and on has
apparent so